Hey guys, Pete here. today we're gonna
talk about predictions for character
deaths in Game of Thrones season eight I
said
ten of them because it's a nice even
number that works out well as far as
time that means that it is in everyone I
think will die in the upcoming season
but limiting the list to ten gives me a
chance to explain my thinking this is
pure speculation based on what we've
seen in the series so far so you don't
have to worry about spoilers or anything
like that
I'll probably end up being wrong about a
lot of these but at this point in time
based on what we've seen what we know
all these seem like pretty good bets to
me you guys can tell me if you agree or
who you think I'm wrong about in the
comments before we jump into the list a
quick update if you watch my last video
I listed off the episode runtimes that
were published last week since that
video came out HBO has made an update
and it's an important one they
originally listed episode 3 as being
only 60 minutes long which seemed way
too short to me turns out after the
update it is now listed at 82 minutes
which means it will be the longest
episode of the entire series this
doesn't change what I was thinking about
in that video or what I was talking
about but it does sound good as far as
the overall timeline of the season and I
think it's an improvement now let's jump
into some predictions. number 1: Greyworm
the very first time I watched the
season 8 trailer installed the pre-battle
kiss I instantly thought that
there was no way our favorite unsullied
would live to the end of the season grey
one's a good character he's been loyal
he's a great warrior
and I think he's gonna die on the field
as a warrior the love story that they
built up over the last couple seasons
seems like it gives his death a push in
the direction of making a real impact
when it happens and I think that it will
happen sometime during the Battle of
Winterfell I have to imagine he's gonna
go down swinging like he's gonna put up
a good fight and I think it's likely
that he will do something heroic before
things go wrong and he leaves the series
for good. number two is Jorah
since we started out talking about the
trailer let's cross Jorah off the list he
was another one that I was like well you
see Jorah there he just doesn't look
like he's gonna make it I feel like he
will have to go there really isn't much
for him to do it
point in the story anymore Daenerys has
Jon and Tyrion - advisor so on some
level he's fulfilled his role like grey
worm he is also a loyal and good warrior
and he has value but there's gonna be a
high death toll when the White Walkers
attack and I was thinking that some of
the secondary characters like HOD
tormund or bran you could essentially
flip a coin for these guys
maybe they'll die maybe they won't it's
you know it's they're they're popular
characters it'll be impactful if they do
die but Jorah is a bit more essential
like he's on a level just above those
guys in my mind and like I said he kind
of doesn't fit anywhere after the battle
so I think he's going down
number three is Qyburn cover it's an
interesting character you know he works
his way up it was an impressive climb to
become the hand of the Queen he had been
kicked out of the Citadel for with the
work that he was doing so he pretty much
started from nowhere but I don't expect
he will still be alive by the end of the
season I don't know exactly when or how
he will die but if for nothing else he
stayed with Cersei after she decided to
go back on her promise to send the
Lannister troops north this will make
him incompatible with whoever takes over
next or whatever happens next
and his frankensteining skills really
don't fit into many scenarios going
forward either I didn't even give the
mountain a position on this because he's
definitely going to die like that's just
not even a question really but a guy
with the ability to make something like
the reanimated Mountain can't be running
around in Westeros after everything is
sudden done either so for that reason I
think Qyburn is through number four
berrak if we're talking about reanimated
people I think it's really safe to say
that beric done there and will die I
think he's gonna play an important role
in the war for the dawn after all they
kept him around for something all this
time but he'll likely die on the field
you know he believes that the Lord of
Light was bringing him back for a
purpose
and Thoris isn't around any longer to
bring him back there is an outside
chance that he might die while
delivering a kiss of life like he did
the books but not sure that show has
really set this up so our favorite
flaming sword wielding fire white will
finally die for real before the
remaining people head south number 5 is
urine urine doesn't have a chance of
surviving season 8 in my opinion
personally I'd be fine with Theon
completing his Redemption art by taking
him out and saving Yara but even if that
doesn't happen there's no way he can get
to the right side of things like he just
can't be on the right side from where
he's at right now every scenario I can
imagine where he stays relevant for even
a couple episodes ending him dying in
one way or another he has a role to play
but it ends with him dead I say good
riddance as well since I feel like the
show version is a real letdown compared
to the character in the books I think
they missed an opportunity to really
create a good character but you know
they didn't feel like they had the time
to flush that out and yeah you're on is
cannon fodder I don't know what he'll go
down but he will go down number 6 is
Melisandre the red woman told us she was
going to die in Westeros and I believe
her what's more important though is that
she believes it herself and that means
it will happen like most of the people
on this list I can't really see her
playing a role in what comes after the
Battle of Winterfell and the main thing
we know about her is that she is
dedicated to trying to save the world
from the great other I think as far as
the show is concerned her dying during
this conflict makes the most sense
hopefully they have something really
cool planned for her and her end will be
fitting george RR martin has said that
she's one of the most misunderstood
characters in the books in his opinion
and i think there's a lot more to her
story there but he or she's just going
to play some sort of role it's what
she's been set up for we'll have to wait
and see what happens but I think it's I
think there's a lot of potential of it
being cool I just don't think there's
any potential of her actually living
past that
it happens number seven is Varys
Melisandre also told Maris that he would
die in Westeros but in contrast to her
that's not why I feel like he's going to
die of course she does see things in the
flames she generally gets wrong what
that is and there's pretty good reason
for that I think but as far as various
it's more of like his time like the time
when he was relevant to the story has
passed
I think Varys has to die for the same
reason that Baelish had to die because
you know those particular skills aren't
really going to be important in the
Westeros of the future first has been a
key player and it would be like really
impactful death I think you know he's
helped things get to where they are in a
lot of ways but my hope is that whatever
comes next won't have a place for him
like I just don't see him fitting I
really have no idea what a good ending
would be for him hopefully he can do
something really good for the realm
before he dies because I think that is
really a motivation of his not just
something that he says number eight is
Jaime
I don't think Jaime Lannister is a
controversial choice to put on this list
in fact I think most fans expect him to
die in one way or another what's
interesting to me about Jaime is when
and how he'll die there's a lot of
speculation about this there's always
been a lot of speculation about this I
guess and you know some people think he
will be the Ballon Carr Cersei fears and
then he'll die right after he kills her
others think that he'll die in brianne's
arms some people even think that he'll
die in brianne's arms arya will end up
with his face and then she'll fulfill
the valonqar prophecy while wearing it
down in King's Landing I'm not really
sure I do feel sure that he'll died of
him killing Cersei has certainly been
foreshadowed and I think it's a good end
to his story but at the same time he'll
definitely be fighting side by side with
Brienne against the White Walkers so
that's a possibility I'm not a fanboy
I'm not really on board with his
Redemption
and I you know I've talked about this in
several videos but I know it's a popular
one people are rooting for him and they
want to see him redeemed so let's just
hope that he gets a nice fitting ending
at the end of the day number nine is
Cersei Jaime's sister
I suppose this is pretty obvious but she
is currently the queen of the Seven
Kingdoms and you know I actually love
Cersei it's one of those love to hate
kind of just love her even though she's
terrible kind of thing so this will be
pretty hard for me to watch she's one of
the few characters actually like better
on the show than in the book and I
really love watching Lena Headey play
her she's objectively one of the worst
characters in the story though and
there's definitely no place for her in
the future of Westeros for all the same
reasons that I just mentioned about
these other characters because of her
position as Queen there are so many
possible ways that she could be killed
off and the show never mentioned the
word valonqar when she visited Maggy the
Frog so you know there's that I still
kind of want it to go that way but I
don't think that it's set in stone I
also don't personally care if aria is
the executioner but I imagine that would
be a fan favorite way for her to come to
an end for her reign to come to an end
if anyone ever doubted that she might
remain on top like she somehow might win
at the end I think that scene with the
sands with ilaria and tyene and the
dungeons you know that pretty much put a
seal on her fate you know there you
don't come back from that one she's on
her way out it's just a matter of when
and I just don't see another way out for
her and number 10 is Daenerys this is
the only one that's a bit controversial
and that I struggle with I'm really not
a hundred percent but I do believe that
the mother of dragons will die before
the series comes to an end basically I
don't think both Daenerys and John will
live based on the ways I've imagined the
story ending over the years I just think
it's slightly more likely that John is
the one who survives obviously Daenerys
is a sympathetic
and we root for her and it would be
great if she could survive I don't
really like in the show how they kind of
made this false thing about her being a
possible mad queen it doesn't really
hold up for me but at the same time I
just think one of them has to die I
don't think they both can live in the
video I made last week about the things
that sort of have to happen for the show
to be good I said that life has to go on
in Westeros you know there has to be
something that happens after this
doesn't end with the battle right so I
don't think it would be impossible for
Daenerys to be a good ruler I also don't
think it makes a lot of sense for a
ruler to come in based on the claim of
the bloodline like how she has gotten to
where she's at
she's not responsible for that that's
the thing that happened but having a
Targaryen with dragons retake the throne
it's just the same kind of story I'm not
a John fan like I mean I like the
character just like I like all the
characters I'm not rooting for Jon like
I don't have an interest in him becoming
like king or anything like that and I'm
certainly not anti Daenerys but I do
think that Westeros will be changed by
the time the story ends if I have to
pick one or the other I think John is
the more likely candidate to do what's
right for the sake of it being right
like regardless of having a better claim
or any of that he is still a bastard
with no claim to anything at heart
that's who he sees himself as and we've
seen him do things for the for the right
reasons even though he's made a lot of
mistakes and Daenerys has done that as
well they do mirror each other in that
way but there's just something that is
making me think that John's story
portrays him as someone who's slightly
at an advantage for being the guy you
want to be holding the keys to drive the
car to wherever it is Westeros is going
at the end and of course you know having
dragons now doesn't mean that she'll
still have those at the end of the story
they could definitely die there's a
chance that all magic will die if you
really look at it that by itself isn't
the reason why I
that it's more likely that Daenerys is
the one who dies I think it for me
personally it would have more impact I
think that's more sad I mean John's
already died and come back like he's
essentially a fire white so him dying
again isn't really gonna have that big
of an impact and like I said with the
Dragons I mean obviously you know John
is going to be a dragon rider as well
that's just a matter of time I don't
think there's really any chance that
that's not going to happen but you know
like I said I do think the knight King
and the White Walkers are gonna have to
be defeated and there's gonna be a large
cost for that humanity's gonna have to
pay a price a lot of the people on this
list they're gonna die as a part of that
but the war against the White Walkers
aren't that's just not the end you know
I mean this isn't a battle that is
decisive as far as what the story has
been about somehow there has to be some
balance to shift away from the way
things were there are a lot of
possibilities for how that goes down and
I'll be making more videos about those
possibilities in the weeks leading up to
the end of the series so I hope you'll
join me for those what do you think who
do you think's gonna die in season eight
do you think that any of these people on
this list are absolutely safe and they
will not die let me know in the comments
I think it's close on everyone really I
mean anyone could die anybody could live
so just let me know what you guys think
and please give me a like on this video
if you enjoyed it think about
subscribing and turning on notifications
and all those things that we're supposed
to say at the end of videos and thanks
for watching guys I enjoy making these
videos I enjoy the feedback in the
comments in the conversation and I'll be
talking to you soon
you